good morning everyone and welcome to
this webinar in this webinar we want to
cover a few things first of all we'll
talk about some of the upcoming ominous
logic online and on-site training
programs than by informatics I do want
to let you know that this webinar is
going to be recorded and so we will be
sharing the recording of the webinar
with all the participants and those
interested to join one of the programs
that we will discuss in today's webinar
will also talk about some of the online
resources that we have prepared for
self-guided learning if you're
interested in taking courses on your own
timeline and schedule we'll talk about
some of those updated materials and
we'll also talk about some of the
bioinformatics resources so let's jump
in I will make causes for any questions
there will actually be a time slot for
you to ask any questions but at any
point in time if you have something that
you would like to ask you can put it on
chat the chat box is open if you go to
the zoom bar and in the zoom bar there's
a three dot button that says more and
you can click on it and open the chat so
if you have any questions during the
session please take a look there if you
want to have this webinar recording at
the end and you have registered for this
webinar you will receive the recording
and you will be able to also view that
recording on YouTube and other social
media where we will post it after the
recording is processed and shared so in
this webinar again like I said we will
speak about some of the upcoming
training programs release sources for
self guided learning and bioinformatics
research and our goal is to introduce
the topics and program details and
answer any questions you might have
about registration about program
participation any topic questions that
you have about any of the programs that
we will be having or anything else that
you feel that is not clear and you would
like
to be clarified my name is Delia Brodsky
I work for Pine biotech and I'm going to
be sharing with you from these details
but also online we have some people
available that are from different
regions where these programs are
happening so if you have a specific
question about programs and India
programs in Nigeria or programs here in
the US we can help answer those
questions as well so we have several
upcoming programs that we want to go
over today
there's a program that will be starting
in two programs that will be starting in
March and one program that will be
starting two courts the beginning of May
the first program that we'll talk about
is precision oncology bioinformatics for
precision oncology another program
introduction to big data and life
sciences and we will have a program
focused on bioinformatics for infectious
diseases so I'll go over some of the
topics that we will have that we will
cover in these programs and also talk
about some of the general things that we
offer either online on-site at different
locations or something Labine formatic
tools that we will utilize all of our
almonds logic programs are designed to
provide theoretical and practical
training for those interested in
next-generation sequencing data and
other high-throughput data that talks
about the molecular changes that could
be studied using data analysis
techniques as you know this data is
becoming widely accessible and collected
focused on a variety of topics and so in
each program that we will discuss now we
will learn about the different types of
data how to process and prepare this
data for analysis as well as how to
utilize data science skills to mine and
visualize large data sets and also
present your research to peers and
experts for feedback and we will also
discuss some of the opportunities where
you might be able to interact with
experts in specific fields and domains
and be able to learn
them and learn about the data that is
available so the first program we'll
discuss today is the bound from attics
for precision oncology program that will
start on March 9th 2020 in this program
will present the background of cancer
research that focuses on oncogenes and
tumor suppressor genes and different
changes in the DNA and RNA as well as
the regulation of these genes at the
genomic and transcriptomics levels the
registration for this program is already
open now and we have limited places if
you want to join this program but to
join the program you can follow this
link which is edu dot T bio infocom
precision oncology 2020 and thank you
beeps yep for posting that link right
then Jack you can you will submit a
registration form on this link and after
your form is submitted you will get an
email notification where you received
additional information on the program
timeline topics that are covered
registration link and other things as
well but what we'll do now is we will go
through some of these topics and some of
this information briefly and then if you
have any questions you can feel free to
either ask them in chat as I go through
the topics or at the end we will have a
slide to pause and have a discussion if
anyone has any questions
so precision medicine as you know is
changing the way that we understand
diagnose and treat cancer this
transformation is driven primarily by
high-throughput molecular data from
patients animal models and large-scale
cell line experiments so this program
what we want to do is explore how the
various omics data types can be analyzed
to understand the basic biology
associated with cancer onset the
development as well as outcomes and see
how large-scale data collected from
research projects as well as clinic
trials provides an opportunity to better
understand this condition and improve
the precision of clinical oncology so
the program will offer access to expert
speakers that will share their insights
into various aspects of cancer research
cancer biology the different data and
data analysis skills and they will offer
guided training sessions where we will
use the different analytical tools
explored data sets and learn about the
biology that we can see by analyzing
this data in practical sessions we will
also together process analyze and learn
how to interpret data and where to find
that data in public repositories we will
break down the complexities of tumor
development and the role of tumor
micro-environment so we'll talk about
changes at the subcellular level as well
as data that is available from all
organisms tissues and combination of
tissues like the tumor and the tumor
microenvironment we'll also talk about
the DNA genes and RNA transcription and
how these elements can be studied using
next-generation sequencing so we'll talk
about how the process of sequencing
works and what kind of information does
it provide that we can analyze and then
we'll talk about how the data could be
processed and study we'll also talk
about some of the approaches in basic
and translational research oncology
where patient derived cell lines
xenograft models where tumors are
grafted into an animal like a mouse as
well as clinical trial data offers a
rich collection of data to inform
diagnostic approaches and development of
new treatment of cancers either based on
new target pathways or based on existing
drugs that might be repurposed to treat
specific processes
as you know the recent growth in high
throughput sequencing of cancer genomes
and transcriptomes has produced a big
data problem that precludes many cancer
biologists and oncologists from gleaning
knowledge from these data regarding the
nature of malignant processes and the
relationship between tumor genomic
profiles transcriptomic profiles and
treatment response and so we will learn
about the different data types and how
to efficiently process the big data that
is available so that we can get some
meaningful insights from that data
together we will map visualize and
detect significant changes in the DNA
sequences using reference genomes and
paired tumor normal samples where we
will learn how to discover mutations
whether germline or somatic mutations in
oncogenes and as well as genes that
suppress the oncogene function we will
study the expression of activated genes
and pathways learn about methods to
perform complete analysis starting from
processing to exploration of data to
interpretation that leverages online
databases of genes pathways and
functional processes that are associated
with found genes and functions the found
genes that we will learn about play a
role in various regulation processes
associated with cancer risk tumor
development and other key factors that
are typical for various types of cancers
and so they activated pathways that you
see here on the screen we will learn how
to interpret them and how to analyze the
changes in those pathways that are
associated with different types of
phenotypic information that we have
about the samples but at the same time
we will learn about the biology of tumor
developments and how the tumor and the
signaling processes are dis regulated in
different cancers because of the genomic
and transcriptomic changes that we can
study we will also learn about
the public domain repositories where
data can be found and lots of data sets
on different types of cancers provide us
with good examples of studies and those
data sets will be curated so that you
can easily find the metadata and the
different types of data that are useful
in their analysis so we will learn for
example about the Cancer Genome Atlas
and the data that could be found there
learning to navigate the genome data
Commons portal which is what you see
right here and how to find and prepare a
multi-omics data set with all the needed
clinical information about the samples
we will also talk about several curated
examples that we have prepared so that
we can learn about the utility of
bioinformatics and precision oncology
research for example we'll talk about a
data set from the publication modeling
precision treatment of breast cancer
which was featured in genome biology in
2013 the publication is interesting
because the authors assembled the data
set of about 50 different breast cancer
cell lines that represent the whole
spectrum of breast cancer variation the
cell lines have genomic transcriptomics
and proteomics data as well as an
efficacy measurement of commonly used in
an experimental cancer drugs so we'll
talk about some of the methods that they
have utilized in this publication and
we'll see how we can run a similar
analysis and the types of outputs that
we get and what they mean for us to be
able to select and understand the
function of different treatments that
have been described in this publication
will also analyze data from liver
hepatocellular carcinoma LHC which is a
project on the Cancer Genome Atlas and
what we'll see is how we can find the
various clinical data that is available
on the patients that are described in
this data and how we can learn to use
the metadata available in the clinical
data sets to study the gene and micro
RNA expression related to these
different types of patients the
different types of phenotypic data that
we will see in
serology pathologic diagnosis diagnosis
being a my obesity and other risk
factors for example infection with
different hepatitis C and B as well as
alcohol consumption
we'll also learn how to find the data in
publications associated with these
studies and find the supplementary data
sets that will help clarify what was
done how the patients were recruited and
what we can find about the different
patients and the types of data that were
collected from them at the end of the
program participants will receive a
certificate of participation if you have
participated in the online sessions and
have completed several different
assignments that will be discussed
throughout the sessions we will also
provide hands-on analysis practice
during those practical sessions you'll
be able to ask any questions and
discover what went wrong in an analysis
that didn't work you will also gain
access to one-on-one Q&A and assistance
with any challenges or project
preparation that you are considering for
your own research or for your own study
you also get an account on the team
Island for platform which I will talk
about at the end that allows you to
process efficiently large data sets and
find all of the tools necessary for
processing analysis machine learning
annotation visualization of the data
that we will discuss so for the duration
of the program you have your account and
you can use that account with five
terabytes of data storage which allows
you to process large data sets and get
them in a form and shape that you can
utilize either in a publication or a
presentation we'll talk about that as
well so again to register please follow
this link this link is available on
chats its edu T bio info comm precision
oncology 2020 and I want to just mention
again that the program will start March
9
20 and will last up until May 16 2020 we
will have bi-weekly meetings every
Monday and Thursday and you can learn
about the schedule and all of the topics
that we discussed here on the link that
we shared does anyone have any questions
about this first program bioinformatics
for precision oncology okay if there are
no other questions again we will share
the recording and you can learn on the
link that we shared with you other
topics and information and if you have
any questions you can just respond to
one of those emails so the second
program that we want to talk about today
is the introductory program that we're
launching for the first time for those
of you in Africa and especially those of
you in Nigeria this program will be much
shorter and will offer an easy
introduction to the big data and life
sciences challenges that are becoming
more and more relevant specifically in
Nigeria and throughout the continent and
so to learn more about this program and
start the registration process you can
also visit this link
edu dot T bio infocom onyx logic
anterior 2020 it's the first program of
that time be sure if you could please
share that link and chat as well thank
you so you can join this program you can
see that it's much shorter it's only 15
days long and it's really an
introductory program and throughout that
program we will also discuss a number of
topics that we will continue to expand
upon in future programs focused on that
same audience so the program is a 50 15
day online program that was developed by
PI endowed biotech together with several
academic institutions and companies in
Nigeria in this program participants
will learn about the impact of genomic
revolution next-generation sequencing
and computational technologies in every
area of life sciences that include the
basic research biomedical research by
the technology in Admiral biology we
will learn how to find understand and
then analyze data using high-performance
computing as well as user-friendly tools
for biologists sessions will be held
online as well as on-site at the
biologic support services limited in
Lagos Nigeria the program is designed
for students and faculty from life
sciences backgrounds in this program we
will speak about big data and how it has
transformed the life sciences as well as
introduced both the challenges and
opportunities into every aspect of
research biomedical discovery
biotechnology and agriculture the
program will be held online with
one-hour online sessions as well I love
self-paced materials that are available
for access online so as you know that
our mcstick knowledge ease are becoming
cheaper and are now used to explore the
roles relationships and actions of the
various types of molecules that make up
the cells of an organism of onyx data
can be generating using next-generation
sequencing or what is also known as
high-throughput sequencing the data can
show detailed information about genomic
variants epigenomic regulation as well
as G&I as a form expression so we'll
talk briefly about these different data
types and we'll discuss how these data
types are used in different areas of
research that have been mentioned we
will start the program with an overview
of different types of omics data and the
significance of the technologies that
are being improved to generate this kind
of data we will speak about
next-generation sequencing or for
high-throughput sequencing and how new
computational methods have been
developed to analyze and process this
data as well as what are the challenges
to interpret the data from the molecular
level information that we have from
every cell in the sample so we'll talk
about the history of omics data
availability of long links data and some
of the challenges and opportunities that
we have in life science research related
to the bioinformatics approaches that
were developed
analyze and interpret this data we'll
also take a look at several examples of
projects and several examples of data
types that could be found on public
domain repositories and are ready for
anyone to take and analyze we'll learn
about some of the machine learning
techniques that are becoming more and
more available and powerful to analyze
big data sets including clustering
dimensionality reduction as well as
classification and the impact of feature
selection or interpretation of
conditions that are sampled from various
data types data types this program will
be an excellent reduction to the
resources materials in a vibrant online
community that you can join to continue
learning about file formats specifically
you will get to experience
bioinformatics for yourself and try the
following find and understanding
next-generation sequencing data what is
the data set or a project about what is
the question that you can ask or you are
trying to ask and can this data answer a
question that you are asking you will
also process data perform quality
control map align and quantify and
evaluate different pipeline outputs you
will also analyze data by learning about
the different statistical approaches as
well as exploratory data analysis and
interpret the data by an annotation
using reference databases and pathway
analysis finally you will consider an
independent project and learn about
future rmx logic programs that will help
you make further progress with the
project with the research and
incorporate some of these tools into
your analysis workflow so we'll also
talk about the student and faculty
resources that we are developing to make
bioinformatics more accessible
throughout Africa and the region the
program will be available online or an
important part of it is that we will
also offer it at the biologic support
services in Lagos Nigeria you can learn
more about the company and their
facilities on this website you can see
one second I will paste the way
so this is the link to their website
sorry and dr. Toya is here with us also
so if anyone has any questions about
this program or about the facilities or
how the program will be conducted please
feel free to ask those questions in the
chat box the program is now open for
registration and at the end of the
program again we offer certificates of
participation and completion for those
that are completing and doing all the
requirements of the program that
includes the attendance and doing some
of the practical analysis so you can
learn more about this program and start
the registration process using this link
that was already shared by beeps yeah
it's edu yu-gi-oh infocom Onix logic -
nigeria - 2020 so there are any
questions about this program or about
the topics or about the participants
that how this is going to happen please
let us know now we're happy to answer
any of your questions yes I see that
read me
I'm you'll have a question okay if you
there isn't an option to raise your hand
and then for read me if you have a
question happy to Internet okay
okay so there are no questions about
this I am going to continue speaking
about the next program that we're
excited to be launching very soon and
this next program we will we will launch
in May will be bound from attics for
infectious diseases in this program we
will learn about viruses and infectious
diseases from viral and bacterial
infections we'll talk about zone otic a
transfer of infectious diseases viral
infections and bacterial infections we
were learning about analysis - that kind
of data including detection of viral
genomes and next-generation sequencing
data vaccine design viral strains and
haplotypes antiviral drugs and
antibiotics as well as study of
epidemiological data and drug resistance
I'm sorry I'm going to pause here
because there is a couple of questions
about the program in Nigeria so the
question is does the program in Nigeria
restricted to only there or can other
individuals participate from other
countries yes it's a Nigeria on site at
the biologics Support Services but
online anyone can join we did design the
program specifically for people in the
African continent we have a foundation
that has supported much lower rates for
people to join that lab program for a
very low and affordable rate so if you
would like to join that program
obviously anyone can join this is an
introductory program and we would be
happy to discuss with you access online
for all of the sessions and yes thank
you Joe for adding that about the
biologic support services another
question here we will also get to learn
about statistical methods that can be
used to analyze sequence data so there
are multiple types of methods that we
will discuss starting from processing
the data so process
the data typically means that the data
needs to be cleaned and some of the
cleaned up data has to be mapped on a
reference genome there are a lot of
statistical methods that are involved in
that process but primarily we will
discuss the statistical methods that are
used for what's called downstream
analysis when we have to compare
different groups of data when we have to
compare different signals and extract
the signal from noise and we'll also
talk about different machine learning
methods that actually use computational
automation for the different statistical
principles that help us detect patterns
and data that are typically not as
obvious and not so easy to analyze with
conventional statistical methods so we
will talk about those in different
programs write an application to
different types of data centers the
oncology will be focused on oncology
data sets this program bioinformatics
for infectious diseases will be data
related to bacterial and viral
infections I hope that I answered your
question there okay so going back to
bioinformatics for infectious diseases
the program will cover different types
of diseases different types of analysis
this approaches as well as provide you
with some curated projects and datasets
and so we'll talk about viruses like
Ebola Zika and dengue that have recently
we've seen large epidemic outbreaks
we'll also talk about corona viruses
like SARS MERS and the novel coronavirus
in Wuhan China as well as some of the
bacterial chronic diseases that have
been around for a long time but are also
a concern such as tuberculosis and
leprosy so we will start registrations
for these for the program in March and
plan to conduct the program starting
around May 2020
primarily focus on analysis of viral
genomes and I'll give a couple of
examples here
in the next few slides so with the
recent epidemics becoming much more
visible dangerous and unpredictable
there's really an urgency to learn about
the different data and how to work with
that data and how can you use that data
to understand the epidemiological spread
of these diseases as well as the
underlying mechanisms that the viruses
views to adapt to new circumstances to
new going from animals to humans and
others and so we'll have a chance to
kind of look at some of these infectious
disease outbreaks that have been really
impacting since though in the last
couple of decades to have been impacting
large numbers of people for example
we'll talk about the novel coronavirus
outbreak and how we can study the
genomes from SARS MERS and the novel
coronavirus outbreak in Wuhan China will
actually talk about what data is
available and how to find that data and
what is this data mean we will also
learn about phylogenetic analysis and
how it can be used to study viral
lineages associated with our origin of
the infection time when that infection
happened and even the location how can
we find those associations we will also
look at some curated data sets that you
can play around with and the key in
these curated data sets is that we
actually break down some of the
information where you can find that
information and how can you utilize that
information how can you actually
download the sequences of those strains
and other type of data that is available
so I think this is very important as you
learn about these outbreaks as the data
becomes rapidly accessible what can you
do with it where can you actually find
what you need to find to make a specific
process clear to you from the data
driven research side of things I will
also discuss different viral proteins
right so we had the genome sequence
those sequences could be found but then
we'll talk about how do we interpret the
changes in the viral genomes to
understand how those map onto the
protein structures and what is the
functionality of what are some of the
insights that you can gain from
comparing the impact of different
mutations on the structural variants and
how we can also understand the
differences between how those strains
develop in animals as opposed to for
example humans so we'll we'll have some
datasets and we'll have some papers and
publications that we will discuss and do
some of the analysis together to
understand what does that really mean we
will also talk about for example a
dataset taken from the Ebola epidemic in
2013 2016 that epidemic has also yielded
a lot of datasets so there's a question
here for the infectious diseases
training particularly the viral
infections will diseases like Lassa
fever be considered so again we're right
now in preparation for this program
based on some of the research projects
that we are doing it that we are working
on and so we have an opportunity right
now to consider a number of different
viral genomes and our purpose here is to
really introduce the bioinformatics
component of that so once you understand
how that works for the examples that we
have prepared for Ebola for SARS MERS
and other corona viruses as well as
dengue and and other viruses I think you
can kind of extrapolate how the same
methods apply to any disease we are not
maybe ready to speak about the Lassa
fever right now but you know in the
context of the program we would be happy
to help and support you if you're
interested in that virus so that you can
start working on that project throughout
the program
so as you remember from the Ebola
outbreak there's also a major component
of understanding the different viral
proteins the changes in the viral
proteins how do we understand the
relationships between the different
strains and the different haplotypes of
the virus as well as how can we
understand what mutations are important
and so in the context of that data set
we will really look at the spread of the
infection and really monitor how the
infections spread and how the viruses
are able to replicate and change as a
result of this spread throughout a large
region and over a period of almost two
years so we will discuss how the
different process could be then studied
using data that is available in the
public domain from the different
patients that were sampled and a lot of
the studies that were done afterwards in
cell culture as well so will really
break down the data set help you find
the necessary annotation for the
different samples and provide you with
several examples that we will actually
work on together throughout the program
we will also talk about how the studies
and the bioinformatics approaches were
actually designed to study the increased
in affectivity
the different mutations and also we'll
talk about how that has led to the
development of a vaccine has that is now
available one second there is also
another question about the precision
oncology program we will will we be able
to work on datasets specifically for
metastasis such as topics like breast
cancer metastasis to brain and bone we
will also be able to learn about the
drug targets and therapy targets for
cancer metastasis
okay so excellent question thank you Jim
Ronnie we do have a project data set on
brain cancer
lung cancer and breast cancer and we
will discuss in detail the process of
metastasis and how does it start and how
to detect it and what other methods like
for example Exodus own analysis of exits
arm and DNA and RNA is available for us
to study early detection of metastasis
so we will talk about that I think if
your question specifically will be
focused on one type of cancer like the
breast cancer and how it metastasizes we
will not necessarily have this you know
an in-depth discussion just focused on
one cancer but we will have different
examples and I think the objective of
these programs is to provide you with
tools and information that gives you
enough understanding and practical
skills to be able to develop a project
of your own and then as you work on a
project of your own we will be here to
support your project and help you make
progress enough in the project to be
able to then present your work to your
peers and as well as to experts and get
some feedback so a lot of the topics
that you're mentioning will be touched
upon whether we will do a comprehensive
overview is really remaining up to you
to decide that that will be your project
and so we will continue to work on that
at the later stages of the program let
me know that makes sense okay so we will
again in the in fact two diseases
focused on Ebola a little bit and talk
about different mutations that were
found and reported on and we will also
prepare some curated data sets that you
can learn from working on them
independently and seeing how the
different data analysis tools really are
used by researchers when they study
these kinds of epidemiological data sets
and obviously one of the outcomes of
that data being available is the design
and the development of different vaccine
approaches as well as different
antiviral approaches antiviral drug
design and we'll talk about
those examples as well and how that is
being successful as a result of
different biome attics efforts and the
availability of this kind of data now do
you have any questions specifically
about the program for infectious
diseases and again you can put your
questions in the chat box okay so the
next portion of the presentation okay
registration sorry there's the question
how can I find info about registration
if you mean the registration for the
infectious disease program in March we
will announce the registration details
so please make sure that the emails that
we send from pine biotech you will see
that you know we send regular monthly
emails so either you can reach out to us
through this email sorry that was meant
yes thank you beach' for everyone you
can reach out to us here and with
questions like you know what is the
pricing what is the availability how do
you access you know any questions please
feel free to reach out to that email but
specifically about the registration for
the infectious disease program we will
be posting that announcement on our
website but also obviously we will be
able to send you an email with that
information so if you leave your
information with us your email address
or contact information we will reach out
to you once we have all of the details
for this last program
okay so the other thing that I wanted to
talk about is really the significance of
knowing how to utilize bioinformatics
for every aspect of data analysis from
experiment design we're sequencing
methodologies and analytical methods are
critical because of the data generation
process to bioinformaticians that
ultimately are facing new challenges
every day with new methods and new
questions from the biologists and all
the way to interpretation utilize I
utilization of these data sets and
insights from the analysis itself and so
here we are really trying to offer
affordable and easily accessible
bioinformatics training that is focused
on biology as a data science which we
believe is really what it is becoming
and to address this challenge we have
designed a number of materials that we
have been developing together with
different research institutions as well
as testing it on different audiences
from clinicians to biomedical
researchers to students all the way from
high school undergraduate and graduate
levels so we're really trying to prepare
structured materials for anyone
interested in learning about
bioinformatics for different types of
Onix data and these include introduction
to my little informatics analysis of
genomic data transcript Donavan data
epigenomic data managing our data as
well as a series of courses on machine
learning and data science and so these
materials are all available on our main
website the main website is this one and
you can go on this website and see under
courses how these materials are
organized now the unique aspect of these
materials that we are utilizing and a
lot of the programs that we have
discussed up until now is that these
programs are available in a personalized
way so you
have you create an account that account
gives you access to specific types of
courses or even series of courses and
you can also track your progress and
always go back to the place where you
left off as well as measure your
participation your progress see it by
analyzing the different datasets and
getting credit for all of the activity
that you do so these materials we also
provide a scour participants to provide
us with some feedback and so we are
really excited that we are getting a lot
of feedback positive feedback from the
people that take these courses now you
have to understand that the courses are
designed for different levels of
students some students are very advanced
with the focused on their expertise and
life sciences or some people that are
participating in a school curriculum or
a course on after University and so
really the different levels if you want
to talk to someone and understand what
is an appropriate level for you and what
is the level of difficulty or technical
skills that are required in a specific
program please reach out to us we're
happy to discuss with you what you can
do to find a starting point for wherever
you are in your bioinformatics journey
and so we've seen a lot of good feedback
about the online materials and so I want
to talk a little bit about how these
materials are organized and what they
can give you so like I said anyone that
joins the platform is given in an
account some of the courses are
completely free some of the courses have
minimal payments associated with them
but basically as a part of that training
you belong to this community where you
can see your own progress you can see
your activity you can also join a
program that is organized and there's
going to be a group of people that are
going through the same journey and so
some of the participants that perform
exceptionally well
are also featured and you can see how
your progress your work your
contribution actually helps you get
visibility and get really recognition
for the amount of work that you are
doing so you can find some of these top
performers here on the leader board and
maybe maybe show you can post a link to
the leader board in the chat box as well
so you will see how you can navigate
some of the top profiles and see what
programs they were a part of and what
was their journey and we also highlight
some of the participants in our blog to
share with our community how these
people joined the program and what have
they gained from the different programs
that we have done now all of this
information is on the main site
edu that T - bio dat info but we also
have other sites that are specific to
different regions so if you have any
questions about that you can also reach
out to that now the courses themselves
are designed in a way that you can
easily navigate the different sections
of a course you can see different key
terms you can also search for different
topics and also download a pdf version
of the material if you're offline you
can still continue to learn there's also
a forum discussion where your questions
are being answered and you can ask any
of the questions related to a particular
course topic or lesson and obviously you
can interact with our curriculum
development team that is focused on
improving the materials and making sure
that the materials that we have are
interactive easily accessible and helped
you learn some of these theoretical and
practical skills now also the learning
is supported by our online violence
chromatics research platform this
platform can be used for research using
a research account or it could be used
for education and where you learn using
the curated datasets that we provide and
your points are accumulated under your
profile for each activity that you do
platform is designed in such a way that
you can find clear explanations of every
step that you do with a lot of different
varieties of methods that you can
compare and contrast and you can also
learn without any coding but it doesn't
stop there you can also take it further
once you learn about the different types
of methods about the different analysis
about how the different data sets and
about different questions that you might
be able to ask of the data now the
platform you can find more information
about the platform and the different
types of analyses and the different
types of data sets that you could be
analyzed with the data beam show again
if you could put this link in the chat
box in this in this platform we'll just
give a little overview you will find
materials on how to use the different
sections for example you can see here
transcriptomic data including
single-cell analysis of transcriptomics
from single-cell chip seek and bisulfite
seek analysis of mutation variant data
copy number variation analysis of
non-coding regions of the DNA as well as
the repeats that are found in the DNA
micro RNA analysis analysis of
microbiome and 16s sequencing from
metagenomic data mass spec structural
biology analysis of structures and you
will also find some focused types of
sections for example for hydrology and
for data Association and integration as
well as machine learning data mining and
some utilities so it's a really broad
platform that allows you to learn the
logic of their analysis and does not
require any coding for you to get
started now once you start and you learn
about these different methods we also
provide with some coursework as well as
examples that you can start translating
those methods into your own pipelines
for
we discussed different packages in our
how to start analyzing and exploring
your data in our studio environment and
many other options like that as well so
make sure that you check out the
platform those of you interested in the
platform itself for research we have
that possible we also have different
support services that you can request
and so you can learn about some of the
pricing and some of the options for
those support services on this link as
well okay so that's the platform the
platform is intuitive and really it does
not require a lot of guidance and so
anyone that is just learning mathematics
is able to use and learn as you use how
to apply these different methods to the
different data sets so here you saw a
quick example of building a complicated
data set and you can also see that a lot
of the outputs are going to be visually
easy to interpret and work with as you
understand what type of data you were
working with and we obviously provide
additional information in some of other
courses that we have designed and some
of the programs provide you with guided
assistant kind of version of the same
tools and data sets when we do these
projects I mentioned some of the
projects today from oncology from viral
and bacterial infections we also have
many others and what we do basically is
we extract data from top publications in
different areas those areas include
oncology neuroscience infectious
diseases and others and what we do is we
extract the methods from that paper and
kind of replicate the analysis that the
authors did but will you once you
understand the data and the methods that
are described what you can do is you can
actually combine the two learn how
combine the two into a novel and
independent project of your own and so
those are really the objectives of these
onyx logic programs is to help you
design a project of your own using this
kind of guidance so we have many
different projects available for example
epigenomic analysis of primary human t
cell differentiation asthma
susceptibility modeling precision
treatment of breast cancer using
multiple types of cell lines and
therapeutic agents viral mutation
landscape study using ultra deep sir cig
sequencing of polio viruses grass mania
Bagheera adaptation and toxic resistance
and pine pathogenesis pathogens analysis
of the changing immune response in
cancer microbiome biomarkers from the
American gut microbiome project whole
transcriptome profiling of cancer tumors
and mouse EDX models deregulation of sub
cellular networks in cancer patients
insect cell lines biologics production
spotted terror from Roberta and rhabdo
virus contamination how to find and
analyze viral sequences in this kind of
data crop drought stress and resistance
using the potato cultivar different
cultivars from the potato species as
well as complex gene regulation neuro
degenerative diseases Ebola the deadly
mutations and finally your project right
so after learning from these examples
the examples that were taken from
curated publications with curated
datasets and prepared for you you get to
apply the same skills and the same
understanding from these programs to
your own data set and your own project
so all of these are taken from
publications like I mentioned and
transformed into guided tutorials that
you can either take online and follow
yourself or join one of the programs
where these projects examples are used
in the training sessions that we conduct
now at the end of these programs
oftentimes the students and the faculty
that have participated in previous
programs they help us prepare their
projects
because they have analyzed the data
explained all of the data and then have
gotten feedback from their peers and
from others on the types of projects
that they have done so that's really our
objectives and next I want to briefly
explain about a couple of opportunities
for any one of you that is joining one
of our programs to do that to present
your project to others so the first one
is a project that we are doing together
with University of engineering and
management this is a bio Olympian and
Biebster if you could please
paste the link to that bio Olympiad site
this is a program that it's actually an
online competition that is organized by
the University of engineering and
management in Kolkata and India in an
association with Pine biotech in the
Society for mater's artists researchers
and technologies technologists called
smart this online event is organized to
develop interest and competitiveness
among students with an interest in life
sciences and our goal for the
participants entering into this bio
Olympiad will be an inspiration among
the young leader learners in a variety
of applied biological sciences now this
specific program is only for students
that want to do problem-solving in
Applied biology within the age group of
16 to 24 years old the contest is open
to participants from across the globe
however they need to abide by the rules
and regulations of the contest there is
a prize for people that will participate
in this contest the first three ranked
holders will win a prize worth $300 US
dollars in total and merge certificate
in addition in the top 10 people will
get merit or two forgets according to
their score there's there are a few
rules and regulations and it's free to
participate and actual competition will
be online but you have to pre rate you
have to actually register to participate
in this competition so please follow
that link that beeps are posted and you
will get more information about that
okay another opportunity for those of
you joining the programs is an upcoming
program conference on computational
biology and bioinformatics that will
take place in April 3 a 3rd and 4th 2020
at the Louisiana State University in
Baton Rouge Louisiana those of you that
are participating in any of the programs
that we have we have a program with the
Louisiana biomedical research Network
and we have programs with different
universities like the Amity University
or University is a suit of genetic
genetic engineering and others you can
reach out to us about participation in
these in this conference we will
actually help you prepare your project
poster if you are in any one of our
programs and would like to present your
poster during the poster session at this
conference which of course you can put
on your resume and you will get feedback
from experts and there are a lot of high
profile speakers at this conference as
well if you would like to join different
topics will be discussed from cancer
informatics and immunotherapy microbiome
and metagenomics proteomics cloud
computing evolutionary genomics and
phylogenetic that we talked about today
biology and infectious diseases and so
really a lot of the programs that we
have been discussed will be also covered
by experts in this in this conference
and you can either join in person or
reach out to us to get more information
after the conference is over
now previous participants of our
programs have been able to participate
in this program so you can see some of
the people presenting their posters from
different universities and we also will
have a workshop during that session you
can submit abstracts and projects done
already if you have not published them
obviously I am going to paste here a
link for anyone that is interested you
will see
details about the conference itself
right here and also the registration
information that you can join and some
of the speakers are described right here
as well so please take a moment to take
a look at this and obviously if you have
any questions I would be happy to answer
those as well
I will finish with um okay so there's
another question the question is whether
you can submit abstracts on projects
that are being done with you know
publicly available datasets so I will
mention that yes many of the projects
that people undertake many of the poster
sessions that people do utilize online
data you know to perform new analysis
right so one of the papers actually that
we will discussed in the oncology
program our papers that you know utilize
existing cell lines but test different
new methods and develop new results and
insights from those datasets and from
the analysis that they perform so
definitely you can use existing
databases you can use existing datasets
you probably need to develop some novel
aspect of the analysis or interpretation
and do some literature review that
indeed you are providing some you know
value to the research community and
that's why that abstract submission is
going to be evaluated by a panel of
experts that have expertise and both
bioinformatics but also some of these
domains that we talked about the cancer
infectious diseases immunology and
others ok so again if you have any other
questions I would be happy to answer
your questions
we have also online here with us some of
our trainers and some of the other
organizers of the individual programs
that I mentioned
so if you have any questions for them we
can answer those as well
you
okay well I hope that we were able to
answer most of your questions if you
have any other ones feel free to reach
out to us by email you will also notice
a chat box on our web sites where you
can ask questions as well make sure that
you check those out and also we have
here beeps ah and Mohit from our program
in India if you have any questions
specifically about Indian locations or
dates we have some upcoming workshops
and opportunities to learn there as well
you can reach out to us to them there we
also have several US programs right now
and it was - like I mentioned and
throughout the state of Louisiana as
well as at Georgetown University and
others okay there's a question here how
long will the certificate be valid for
so the certificate is issued for a year
we actually specify the date on the
certificate so twelve months from that
the certificate is valid because we
expect to cover a lot of the methods
that are relevant but the field is the
dynamic the field of mathematics is
dynamic and so we encourage people to go
and continue and learn after they get a
certificate from a program however this
certificate is really going to
demonstrate that you have participated
in a program that has been evaluated
rigorously by a variety of academic and
industrial institutions it is in
collaboration with the Taliban
informatics Research Center from
University of Haifa in Israel the people
that have developed and continue to
develop the team valuing for platform
it's also in collaboration with a number
of other organizations that we mentioned
on the certificates so the certificate
is going to be good for the next
foreseeable future but we do encourage
you to update your training at least
once a year and participate in programs
that provide you with updates to the
different
technologies and methods that are
emerging in these bioinformatics markets
okay for those of you that maybe just
recently joined we are just wrapping up
here we will send the recording of this
webinar with all of the commonly and
frequently asked questions in follow-up
email please look out for that email
we've covered a lot I'm just going to
again review some of the upcoming
programs just so that those of you that
are interested and you know you can see
what we are planning in the near future
we have a program upcoming for
bioinformatics for precision oncology
program that is an introduction to big
data in life sciences as well as
bioinformatics for infectious diseases
and we discussed today a lot of the
online materials and resources that you
can utilize in your research as well as
to learn about balanced rheumatics
starting from basic and beginner level
all the way to advanced research level
thank you again for joining this webinar
if you have any other questions please
make sure to reach out for us to us and
look out for those upcoming emails where
we will be sending you more information
about these programs and online
materials thank you again and I look
forward to seeing you in one of these
upcoming programs